hey Doug I'm over there ah me as long as
you didn't climb in a laundromat still
the best joke in Sonic the Hedgehog the
afternoon show I would argue with
anything Sonic fan showing actually does
under sonic I know but you know it's
just so soft even in the good Sonic the
Hedgehog stuff it's like nothing's gonna
top that you know it's a mixture it's
what we saw that we act we literally
laughed out loud
we're just like that is the most bizarre
thing it is it's the sort of thing that
a writer at their wit's end just
completely bereft of ideas goes I got
nothing like all right let's go pure
desperate hey look I'm over there and he
looks look what it works it really
worked there is something to when you're
just pushed against a corner and you'll
just say or do anything that desperation
that sometimes give really oh no that
was the equivalent of playing cards
against humanity and playing a random
card because you're like Dale stark boom
and it wins and like real yeah it's got
a good scene so yeah with that said
we're going to talk about the the both
Sonic cartoon shows it back in the in
the 90s the one that ran on Saturday
morning or satya my guess is it's known
Satan and the one that was I think it's
indication because it came on every day
not surprising what I always remember to
it as the afternoon show because I can't
remember coming on afternoons like yeah
um and in the review I I get super angry
and I compare the two together oh my god
I can show that I hated that show and
when I was a kid watching it no I
actually did think I really and I was
not like a huge Sonic fan I just hated
this show cuz I didn't get it I didn't
understand Erie little secret we never
owned a Sega Genesis earlier little
secret Santa Christ never owned
yes wait try the way wrong word that
he's trying to handed everyone yeah I
make up for what he meant to give what I
did not have but I did not understand
back then that this is the equivalent of
like what the Adam West Batman was you
know this I pretty 90% sure this was
meant to be stupid the funny thing is I
actively hated it I the the afternoon
show I was just largely indifferent to
I'm like well it's meant for little kids
that came on what early my 92 93 someone
I was like 12 or 13 and I'm like
whatever I'll go watch Animaniacs is
just one of those things like I didn't
care so I didn't actively hate it I was
like well there it is that for me next
well I think too because this is the
time where you know we again we were
talking about the gritty 90s and so are
the gritty early 90s in the gritty 80s
uh where things were starting to get a
lot brighter and we were promised all
this dark stuff the Mario Brothers movie
book was gonna be dark in all a section
here what's gonna be muscle-bound and
gritty and stuff and we weren't yet
again oh no no no and we were and then
we got Batman Forever and stuff
everything was getting like really
lightly sugar-coated so I think there
was back then now we have for a while we
got sort of about surplus of them uh but
back then there was sort this crave for
actual darker stuff cos for younger
people at least our age because things
were going lighter so when the Saturday
morning so when the Saturday morning one
came on
even though really if I was to make a
show out of Sonic the Hedgehog I
probably do like the afternoon one but
the woman that they took it and they
didn't get like so gritty and so dark
any buy back then I mean yeah Batman
came out was a lot darker in x-men and
stuff but for back then it's like okay
we're gonna do is hype a hedgehog that's
really fast blue hedgehog fighting this
giant robotic guy and they really made
it pretty gritty pretty grim and they
good environmental message that is not
they often babies through effort into it
that you'd never think like what I think
summer twos remember we're coming off of
the Super Mario Brothers Super Show yeah
with both the Mario Brothers cartoon
The Legend of Zelda and let's be honest
it was a corporate shield move like
throw something out there anything slant
on Nintendo's name on it yeah it was
very obvious but we were kids and we ate
it up um only now did we look back and
laugh yeah but yeah when that came out
there was so much effort thrown into it
for something that could have been like
the afternoon show um I'm actually
surprised that they they've launched
both yeah III don't know how that didn't
work um but it's just weird that it's
like and we have this one during the
week which is really bright and colorful
and goofy and we have this really
serious when we throw this effort in on
the weekends but I it has never happened
like since then or before I say member
to Mario Brothers shows running
concurrently at one point were there I
thought wasn't there Super Mario 3 or
Super Mario no that came out after the
Marvel after that yeah every time you
again come up ahead new show um but yeah
of its head it doesn't it doesn't happen
often no I cannot even think of another
time maybe there is one you imagine
having a Batman the Animated Series
during the week that was a night braving
the wall I was like that was like the
Adam West series like just completely
goofy and colorful man a man a man in it
and then like Batman the Animated Series
that we know running on the weekend like
all dark and you know and I don't think
it happens much because from a marketing
standpoint that just be a nightmare like
you know you're trying to sell the toys
well which sonic is this this is the
sonic i watch during the afternoon or
the sonic at watch on Saturday morning
like a kid wouldn't even know how to
explore this one advantage there is that
they're gonna look the same no mana yeah
Batman you can't goof up Sonic like he's
gonna look like Sonic the Hedgehog no
matter what you can't make him look any
dirty I guess you could make him look
darker but he's gonna be unrecognizable
so yeah uh so so yeah we have this um we
have the show that is clearly just
supposed to be goofy but everyone wanted
me to review this show and they wanted
me to be angry and mean
and watching it I'm like it I can't do a
whole episode dedicated to this so let's
to be happy
angry about it just it was what it was
just a cheap show for five-year-olds
meant to get a few quick cheap laughs
like I can't I can't invest the hatred
in it like well I think even even in
terms of sir reality uh it's it's kind
of creative of it just how fucking
straight I it's like does he like a
phone to his hand and just make a
pumpkin or something like Bailey good
how does that work
maybe tell the writers was just either
higher just like nobody's watching do
whatever the hell yeah uh so I mean
varies creativity to that and then with
the with the other one the Saturday
morning one uh the Saturday morning one
I put on par with like the Disney
Afternoon shows I'm so impressed that
they took something that's so sonically
it's better yeah I mean it I don't know
if I could yeah I if you know it's on
far at least I only one the only one
that I thought had a really interesting
story arc probably the beginning of duck
tales where they went the tailspin
handsome interesting story tales
financing adjacent story arcs but they
it kind of a goofiness and that's fine I
loved it did the the early Disney
Afternoon stuff there was sort of a
lighthearted sort of goofiness to it
that I don't think the Sonic Saturday
morning one had as a solitary morning
what was more serious well when tales
when the Disney Afternoon went dark it
was just the right amount of dark it was
okay we're gonna go heavy but not scare
your kids too much heavy you know sonic
I could see like fuck inside the
Hedgehog I could see kind of scaring
little kids but the scenery was no
characters get roboticize are scary
scene there's you know what it is it's
and we joked about this it's like The
Empire Strikes Back there's a kind of
relentlessness to the villains and you
feel like you're always on the run in
the show well that's something that I
don't think the Disney Afternoon really
did much it was always a villain of the
week and this and that there wasn't this
plot that seemed to last a whole season
like even like Rescue Rangers with fat
cat he kind of showed up randomly like
this one this was a revolution story
like ribbons Hunger Games
take back what's rightfully ours and
we're gonna defeat the evil empire it
was very Star Wars for what it was right
down yeah it looks like Endor with the
forest yeah no I mean and that's some
bezel the great things about the
original Star Wars is that they they
almost always opened on a downer you
know and it was when you really look at
yeah there's actually adventure but it's
like you're fighting this this empire
that is taken over everything and this
is kind of the same thing and you're
yeah there is sort of this uncomfortable
feeling like you want to fight back
against these people but for now you
have you have to just be a rebel you
have to sort of hide it in the woods and
stuff and these guys are always after
you but we're just me afternoon showed
yeah and they're in a there is a legit
you know when you're watching as a kid
it it gets you more sucked in and get
your adrenaline going a tad Vitara did
the same thing guys have one advisor you
have everything back and yeah and I
think that's a key it's like you never
saw when things were great it seems to
just start off like well we've already
lost time to fight back like and it
works like as a kid like you're just
sucked into it immediately well I think
I was older and was watching it really
sucked in I was like 14 and I'm like
this pretty good I think the reason it
especially works for kids is because
kids have a lot of energy majority of
them have things pretty good I mean you
know you're kidding parents gonna take
care of you you watch cartoons and stuff
like that uh but so there is something
when you have a lot of air do you have a
lot of adrenaline and stuff and you're
you're super active you want to go play
one do all this stuff and they give you
a world where you need to have a lot of
energy you need to be on your guard you
need to have your adrenaline out strong
what uh yeah and I think that's why
those shows we do remember them so well
and they do hold up so well as an adult
I'm your chit after a while you're just
like give me the afternoon show I'm just
things are tough now job work whatever
but you know when you're a kid you crave
that stuff he was as much of it as
possible on these shows when they put
you in a world you know this dystopia
were just this evil empire whatever it's
taken over
you're constantly of your guard and
that's kind of what you want you want
your energy constantly up and you want
to show that kind of gives you that uh
so it really was well put together um
the the only thing looking back now it's
my Kaz
looking at soar like the old convicts I
used to draw and stuff and I was very
inspired like I was like start combining
like Animaniacs and x-men those are
always County somehow Heights which
nowadays is kind of a common thing you
can take like you were pretty out there
no no but nowadays like you're like
fucking adventure time or like Steven
universe's I mean you can take you to
the goofy ideas yes yeah no but that
really is what I think I think kids back
then just want to take the things they
like combine together you know even
avatar could get really goofy but really
serious too
so I think people sort of like that
combination and I definitely saw with my
style uh you know the really big heads
and the tiny bodies and I'm realizing
like I think I really got that from like
Sonic and probably Tiny Toons they had a
bear that too but in Sonic it's what
those heads would just fucking fall over
they'd have to drag them around I'm
guessing from the video game yeah
probably it's a little bit but I don't
know if they looked especially big in
the show um but uh yeah good good guy
Jim Cummings as um robot oh god I'll
just - Cummings and anything come on
yeah I mean but there is something like
how do you make goods is I scary and
give me very Vader ask with the voice
I'm like I guess it's this terrifying
good - yeah no there's just mr. Cummings
I can't even remember what episode it
was but there was one where it's like
he's he likes today you know he's
yelling at him and then whatever sonic
turns off all the power in the play all
the power goes off and then his red eyes
light up to light the room and he's got
this sneer he just looks at nibbling
with the red eyes clapping his face out
like oh my God my back is terrified but
it's wonderful cuz that's what we want
as kids we want something darker but not
like you know we're gonna fucking punch
you in the face dark you know just
endless violence we want like something
that was smart and also gave you hope -
and that was a legitimately like good
balance and again we were talking about
these two shows being on at the same
time and how confusing back again they
had the same voice actor yeah sonic uh
yeah I would have killed it in the
Saturday morning Wednesday i won
chili dog yeah how did chili dog even
existed at work um but uh we sourced it
from local meats from the forest all the
callable oh not cannibals I'm just
saying we lost a few along the way
emissions what are you gonna do got a
recycle we're all the carnivores here
right except for maybe the squirrel but
uh I also my bench tails I was gonna say
I really like the big down plate tails -
oh I think we all did
yeah I mean it's like ok you need a
little kid character fair enough and
they they were just like no you're just
we're gonna put more attention to the
adults at this one Holy Smoke because we
didn't own a Genesis by had friends who
had a Genesis and playing Sonic - and
everything I I felt they never got tails
right in any incarnation I'm not trying
Majan him as that much of like this
little overhead yeah like I just kind of
thought he was like a lesser sort of
Sonic partner or something like I don't
know I always thought was weird that
they skewed so young but it's a kid show
you got your hero yo you need your Robin
you need your Jubilee you need the kid I
what everything I don't know um you
should have made the chili dog this
sidekick mr. legs
puppy oh no he's not chili dogs is tails
its people so yeah that's our conspiracy
theory I guess oh but uh the split is
dark is the show so yeah I mean I guess
some up I don't never was really hate
the afternoon one it is what it is and
it's like say what I hate hanna-barbera
cartoons it's like they're if they're
meant for little kids
like I do hate Hannah I don't wanna be a
stamp um the the billion wind up like
play-doh I it's just cuz scooby-doo was
too smart for you okay admit it you can
never figure out who the ghost was I I
admire their creativity but I never had
you gotten to the show and they're not
bad forget there
that I just don't like them uh ever a
little bad but not much but just
actively hates them like it just it is
what it is I saw your toons are just
aimed for kids and yeah I can't watch
scooby-doo be like fuck it scooby-doo
what the hell you should be talking
better eat like how do you doing me I'm
like a fucking hate Barney the Dinosaur
a fucking Haytham I think you're the
wrong audience yeah it's kind of the
same thing uh but no honestly four four
little little kids a hand of our bears
stuff is fine I like it was a little
little kid beside I never got the
primetime thing I saw the captain noon
show it's electronic babysitter that's
it here's some bright images the kids
sit there eating their fruit snacks are
no it's not it's not making you dumber
you know it doesn't have any bad
messages some of them are a little too
thinking a little too I had like a live
inside the launch of the Saturday
morning show that was amazing
yeah that's an actual legit good show
which is still corny don't get me wrong
before you grow up and watching that so
then that one was for like all ages hey
don't get wrong it's still well corny
you know med for twelve and
thirteen-year-olds and sonic the fucking
head hog but fruit on a show bed for
twelve thirteen year old it's really
damn good it's a good good show not
quite Batman good with it it's actually
insane a Animaniacs is goofy well it's
the fucking enemy that is yeah exactly
what are you expecting it's still a
cartoon to a certain degree um so uh no
it's a really good show and you should
probably check it out it's I'm the
biggest sin and to this day I hear they
continued it in a comic series which I'm
gonna have to look up but the way it
just got canceled on that cliffhanger
I like to this day I'm like no because I
was invested it was a great living I was
really investing like who is that guy
what's going on and it's like silence
pecans sold I was like fuck um so yeah
and I'll see I'm like it didn't deserve
that they really didn't I agree
I'll be as so many people are trying to
like send me these emails and tell me
what it is I'm just like it's too late
guys I'm just trying to see bunker it's
something with it I'm kind of interested
but it's just too late in the sense that
you know what I
haven't known for this long maybe it's
better just to leave the mystery nothing
can actually deliver what we thought
well it's like I a rhythm now if you are
a gift you are really off I thought I
was like oh you're on oh and go on go go
go look it up I'm sure small dot it's
like I read that I read dune way back in
the day the the original Frank Herbert
series and he died before he finished it
and that was his son and another writer
have finished it and everything and like
it had been so long since I read it and
always kind of wondered what happened
but I think now I'm just kinda you know
what I'm kind of just okay with the
mystery like maybe I'll just never know
or maybe it's one of those things like
on my deathbed two people will come up
and tell me the ending to Saturday
morning and the ending to dune I think
but oh those really cool I wish I saw
that yeah but I I mean I don't know if
it's worth looking up anymore like I'm
kind of like you know what I'll just my
imagination will fit with it oh yeah
it's kind of more fun that way that some
things you just you don't know it's a
mystery yeah like with avatar I
legitimately want to know what happened
to Zuko's mother so I've read the comics
and if they do a core series I would
love to see that continue well it also
helps with that though that we just had
Korra yeah hey Roberts not avatars not
that all that's we're still a little
under ten years on that I mean we're
Sonic show it was what 93 94 yeah
they're like your interest just kind of
changed yeah even if you do it for a
living even if you talk about it for a
little bit it's a great show if if you
want a good old-school cartoon like you
know particularly for one of those
people that was like born in the late
90s and missed it like looking up yeah
if it it was a really really good it was
a good combination way better than had
any right to be it was a good
combination of sort of bright-eyed you
know animals talk--i sir like Tiny Toons
mixed with you know sort of the
harshness of like x-men or baby
you imagine if they had done a zelda
show or Metroid show like that patch way
would be a basic how amazing that would
be either one like where you took it
serious I mean all we got was excuse me
princess I still kind of argue that
Zelda honestly it's bad don't get me
wrong but I if you were to take off the
name Zelda I would kind of enjoy
watching that it's just you don't want
to see you like it solve the Kings
problem with this water talk I know I I
have to be us I literally enjoy the
banter between wig itself
oh I don't mean yeah I will say this I
think that's probably the biggest
problem is when you throw Zelda on it
that's I don't know that's I can't even
come up with an equivalent but you just
don't just don't
it was out of now he's like this whole
mythos I had it been any other character
back then though the games were like
Zelda one two and three like there was
an air of seriousness to them they had
no idea what to do they weren't banter
wise if you work the name off it's like
it's a fun dumb stupid cartoon with a
Mario one even if you took the Mario off
it's like now that's just stupid I mean
it's not fine it's not well animated but
the Zelda wanted actually like I what we
were watching I'm like you know this is
not zelda and its really stupid but I'm
laughing at something every kind of here
we'd be like taking x-men and turning
magneto and um Xavier into like
something out of grumpy old men yeah I'm
living in a cabin era and like if you'd
be like entry this is really pretty
funny it's hilariously written but the
fact that their names are a tad yeah no
this doesn't work i watch somebody
trying but to kind of deal with that her
xavier fires magneto that what if he
domes or whatever it is i mean some can
work it as a comedic sketch but could
you see a show yeah no probably not
oh but that was - did you see a movie
now I'll say no but those sketches could
you see them totally doing that at a
convention yes is it somebody get up and
they do it at a convention yes so don't
make a whole show B's here
so yeah that's our two cents on the
thoughts of Sun it shows and
we'll just yeah the next time we have a
Saturday morning show that probably
doesn't deserve as much talk as we gave
it but goddamn it we're going to because
good shit deserves to be good shit and
talked about the one sends me know who
he walks I don't want to talk about Oh